[Music] Hi, I'm Chad. I'm an architect at
Palanteer. Today we've got Christopher who
leads some of our manufacturing work. Thanks
for joining me. Thank you, Chad. So, I know we
were going to talk about a lot of different stuff
today. One of them being bombs or bill materials.
Pretty central to manufacturing and kind of
the trade compliance and how do I make sure I'm
following all the rules and regulations with trade
across the globe, especially as things are rapidly
changing right now. how do we how do we manage
through that? So maybe you can talk a little bit
about what you're doing in that space. So a lot
of when you think about uh bills of materials or
bombs and how you you frame that um we're really
focused on taking actually what goes into the
three sort of like silos of the business. So in
engineering data you have all of your bills and
materials you may have in that PLM system drawings
or other information that can tell you what you're
actually building. But then you often like cross
reference that with another system such as an ERP.
This is where you're actually seeing what's going
into the products. What's my customer orders that
then in the trade compliance world also kind of
like starts to look at um what are the HTS codes
and how how do they apply to those products. So
typically those teams are super super siloed. So
when you try to do different use cases, you're not
necessarily getting the benefits. But via the AIP
platform and using the ontology, we're bridging
the gaps in those worlds. And that's what's
leading us to a lot of different workflows. Very
cool. So yeah, bringing the data together between
the kind of the contextual engineering specs and
components that are in a lot of different places
and the actual context of transactions in real
world combining that to understand like where
is their opportunity. So it's very cool. I I so
I'd love to just actually see what you're talking
about here because I think it makes more real when
we talk about bomb. It's very kind of opaque idea.
But why don't we just take a look? Awesome. So
if we look at the screen over here, this is Onyx,
which is our notional medical manufacturer and
distributor. So they have some different bills
and materials of some assemblies that they're
building. They build different syringes,
which might be available, and they also build more
complex uh products such as T99 ventilators. When
we actually go into this ventilator, we can
see here via the ontology that we've pulled
up all the subcomponents that that are coming
in. And through that combination of ERP data,
uh, country of origin data from trade compliance
and engineering data, we can actually come here
and see, okay, what are the annual volumes
on these components? Which countries are they
coming from? What's our spend? And so all this
together is because we have the ontology that's
bridging the gaps between these systems. So we
can have one view of all this data. We can also
actually look more on like a hierarchal level
of like what's actually happening. So here we
took that ventilator assembly and we can take the
top level components we can see like what are the
mid assemblies and then what's happening at the
bottom. And so again where that uh ontology really
comes into play is if we zoom in on a specific
component and we kind of like look around we
can see all the different objects which might
be related to that in the ontology. So a bomb
component is going to have its parents. It's going
to have any recommendations on what might be the
materials. You're going to have some drawings
other metadata or maybe even the supplier.
So if we look at something such as a drawing,
we then start to bring that out into our view
and you can imagine that we're going across many
many different systems which are typically siloed.
Yeah, that's neat. So, so really the ontology
is mapping out the not just like here's what in
a bomb, but actually the hierarchy, how they fit
together, the materials, suppliers, everything.
It's like it's the data, the logic, the action
that makes up how I actually produce a product.
Exactly. And while this looks super simple, a lot
of companies have multiple PLM systems, which is
where the engineering data comes from. Maybe
even multiple ERPs cuz perhaps they like grew
by acquisition. They might have different types
of components that way. And just bridging beh
and some of it's very unstructured data too cuz we
get into the engineering side. Sometimes it's the
the drawings of it uh of an actual subcomponent
and the materials and like it's not always nicely
in a in rows and columns. So sometimes this
is very unstructured m or like mixed with very
structured data from like ERPs and that that's
where I think really a lot of the complexity
comes in is is bringing all of that unstructured
and structured data to get the real view of
what's going on. Exactly. And then typically where
customers like get started is they're attempting
to go into in into these drawings and like writing
down different elements and it just it's it it's
super super complex for them. Yes. So looking
into like some of these bills of materials,
this like actually then starts to bring a
lot of workflows to the forefront from a
found foundry and AIP perspective. So you might
be using these to do something for let's say
obsolescence management throughout your bills of
materials. So let's say you have a a company and
these guys are switching um in their ventilator
assembly, they're switching the PCB supplier from
one co company to another. So if you actually
think about that, you need to be able to say,
okay, from an engineering perspective, I validated
this and I'm going to swap my PCBs, but then when
I have different plants, um it's like, are those
plants actually on that revision of the bomb right
now in their ERP system? And then when's the right
point to do a cut over, right? Because if let's
say you decide to cut over the product and start
using the other one, the other the other elements
that are left over might need to be scrapped
because it's no longer in your as per like your
customer specifications, right? So that's one
point where you can actually capture a lot of
value from this type of workflow. Yeah, especially
in the manufacturer space. Like I always love to
see customers starting at the bomb because you can
get to cost of goods sold, engineering standards,
engineering change over, you know, inventory
levels, procurement, like it really is the
center of of the business that is so powerful
and unlocking use cases like this. Exactly.
Even even sales when you think about it, right?
Because if when you're quoting a new project,
what did it cost before? What was the impact? How
do I try to pass that along? Right. Exactly. So,
what we're going to look at now is actually how we
can use this in a different realm which is more so
around trade compliance. So, there's been a lot
of different changing regulations towards trade
lately. Um, we have tariffs that are coming in
for different reasons such as steel and aluminum
tariffs, IPA, etc. And so, we really want to
see how can we use this data in the platform
to make sure we're compliant. And then through
compliance, we can actually reduce our exposure
to the terrorists themselves. Yeah. So what you're
saying really is it's not only just that like,
hey, these things are changing, but it the bombs
can be so complex and subasssemblies and you know,
how much aluminum does that PCB board have on
it or whatever those things are that it's not
that like I'm trying to skirt anything. It's
actually coming back to like how do I make
sure I'm compliant and not overpaying, I'm not
underpaying, that I'm doing the right thing,
I think is really what this comes back to.
Exactly. It's completely about doing the
right thing because if you actually see how some
of these uh HTS codes are structured which flag
for these you do have material specific ones that
yes this comp this component is made out of steel
or it's made out of aluminum. You then also have
functional ones. So this is a propeller blade and
a propeller blade is going to flag potentially
for a steel tariff, right? But if you're an
engineering company and you use different types
of materials etc. Maybe your propeller blades are
made out of plastic. And so the only way you're
going to know that is being able to actually
go through here to either make sure that you're
being assessed on the correct content of steel and
aluminum in that item. Yeah. Okay. That's Yeah.
That adds another layer of complexity to that cube
of trying to figure out like what am I supposed
to, you know, do for this compliance uh is very
complex. Exactly. Right. And then what you're
typically going to see is that customers don't
even know where to start. So maybe they have tens
of thousands of parts in their like subasssemblies
and components in their part catalog and maybe
they want to start on like okay maybe this
was the one I imported last month but that's not
necessarily forward looking either right so that's
where that ERP data is really important because
you can then start to get this intersection of
um where what are the parts that I'm going to be
importing the most of based off of my forecast
etc in the next few months and then how do I then
go through the bills and materials of those and
prioritize is which ones do we need to update our
documentation to make sure that we're compliant
and reduce our overall exposure. Awesome. Yeah.
So, let's see how we do that. All right. Perfect.
So, if we look at the screen, imagining I am
a trade compliance uh manager in the Sterling
Heights uh department. I'm looking through here
at some different proposals that have coming out
from the AIP system and they're making different
recommendations to ensure that I have the optimal
uh trade compliance amongst my components. So,
there could be a recommendation that's coming
through because I historically put all of my
RFQS into the AIP system and it realizes that
I'm getting uh hit with a tariff on a component
that was actually cheaper from a vendor in the
United States who originally bid on the project.
So that's a type of recommendation saying, "Hey,
maybe we should go look at that vendor again and
see if they could take over the volumes." But
there's some other aspects of this as well. One
of them is for USMCA certificates. So here we can
see a different part number that's being flagged
saying that we had a USMCA certificate in 2023,
we had one in 2024 and we should reach out to get
the one for 2025 to ensure compliance. Um, these
are yearly renewals, so you really need to be on
top of that in order to capture all the value.
The other more kind of like interesting one is
that we see some flags for some components that
potentially have no steel or aluminum content
in them or partials. And so because this has
now been flagged by the system, we're going to
look a little bit further into what we can do
um to assess this. So moving to the next screen,
um we have now my action queue where the AI has
queued up different actions for me to look at.
I'm going to focus on specifically the section
232 content analysis. And I can see I have two
potential assembly parts that I'm bringing in um
that are being hit with steel and aluminum tariffs
and the system is actually recommending to me that
they may not actually have steel and aluminum or
maybe partial. So how that kind of like works is
we go through these different steps. So there's
a component flag for section 232 from the live
broker data. We then have different components
that are analyzed in that bill of materials and
then the entire assembly is being analyzed by
AIP. So, we see here this enclosure. Um, it's an
enclosure that's coming in from Mexico. The annual
volume is 100,000 units. We're spending 410,000.
All from the ERP data. We know this. And then we
have a potential tariff impact of $100,000 that's
coming through. Um, but when we actually look
here, AIP has flagged this as having no steel and
no aluminum content. So, that gives us the ability
to start to then go to the subcomponents in this
bill of materials. We have some parts drawing
from our engineering data. And we can start to
see here, okay, this is a plastic feet standoff,
different card slot brackets. Um, if we want to,
we can pull up the spec sheet as well to see this
is actually a text spec sheet for for a polymer.
So that makes sense. And then we have the ability
to accept or reject these recommendations. Uh,
typically when we look into something like
this with trade compliance, you do want to
have a human in the loop who's making this final
decision right before you you file these. Um,
so the importance here is that AI is being used
to prioritize these based off of impact. Kind of
like the 8020 rule of saying 20% of the parts are
going to have most impact. Um, and then you have
your trade compliance team actually do the final
assessment and collect any documentation they need
in the platform to actually go take action on
these. Yeah. Cuz the inverse of this when you
don't have this is you're opening up specs, going
through PLM's, emails, spreadsheets, trying to
find all the complex subasssemblies verse here's
the one that we think has the most impact and
all the information about it. We think this is
the right call. Yes or no? I think that's like
a distinct difference of the before and after.
Right. Oh, exactly. You could be spending like one
day just trying to analyze these parts if you're
just looking at the drawings and trying to move
through that on your own. So, I mean this is cool.
Like this is a notional example. This makes a lot
of sense from like this plastic. I have aluminum
tariffs and I want to go through and as your bombs
get very many levels deep and they're super
complex with thousands of items. It's hard to
track. Like how are customers doing this? I guess
this is inspired from customers. Yeah. So a lot of
customers are actually doing very similar work to
this. And it's funny where they typically start is
um I'm just going to pull up all my PLM systems
and go into spreadsheets and just attempt to do
this. And you see it taking like days to even
just process one part, right? Wow. Um Yeah. And
that's got to be hard because if it takes you a
day as things are constantly changing and moving,
knowing that kind of impact can be very hard.
So every time something changes, you have to
kind of reassess those impacts. And I think that's
that's really the power of AIP here. Exactly. And
even just in the ontology of storing these parts
because you could be assessing the same components
and the same assemblies over and over and over and
you wouldn't know that if you're just working in
spreadsheets. Oh wow. Oh yeah. Cuz the the sub
assembly that goes to multiple different parts,
you could be reassessing all of those as you
go down the tree could be very difficult.
Interesting. Exactly. Yeah. So, so from an impact
standpoint, like you know, doing this at scale,
it's not only just the the human component of
like I'm not spending a day doing each one, but
it's the I'm in compliance, not getting fined, and
two, I'm saving money because I'm in compliance,
I'm not overpaying. So, I think there's like
three big wins there. Not only beyond just the
kind of the the human piece of it. Exactly.
Right. It's being in compliance so that you
don't have to pay these anymore. and then also
actually going back and saying now that you have
all your documentation together in one in one
place can I go back and recover these right so
there's actually potential on both sides very cool
if we take a look further actually just wanted to
zoom into a specific example here so more complex
than a component that may not actually have steel
aluminum in it but was flagged is when you have
partial steel and aluminum content so in this case
it's another type of uh enclosure that's coming
in from Mexico and It has a a lower tariff impact,
which is why it's kind of like below the other one
on the list. It's flagging as no aluminum content,
but it's flagging as it does have steel content.
And the reasoning from the model is that there
are these three specific components in it that
are explicitly described as steel, right? Um,
so when we go through here, we actually see, yeah,
there's a lot of different plastic housings. There
might be a washer that is made out of nylon,
but there is a steel screw. We may have some
different information that goes through such as
like a drawing where hey this actually if we zoom
in here in this little block we can see that it's
stainless steel. And so the key is is that we need
to be able to process through all of these very um
quickly and efficiently to even know this in the
first place so we can bring this up to our teams
to accept what we're looking at. And that's where
uh AIP logic is really coming into play. So that
way we can have an AI agent which is doing a lot
of this pre-processing to make sure that our
trade compliance teams are just focusing on
the real impactful work of actually putting the
package together and closing these out. Very
cool. So you said AIP logic. What is that? So AIP
logic is one of the tools in the AIP platform that
allows us to orchestrate LLMs to be able to work
throughout the ontology. So I'm actually going to
pull one of those up right now. So this is
the tool we're looking at. Um, and this is
where we're starting to design how we're going
to have our AI agent, which is moving through
these bills of materials. I'm going to open up
a uh test case for us so that way we can see
um exactly like what we're looking at. And so
I'm going to run this on one of the components
as an example and then walk you through exactly
what we're seeing. So the first thing that we do
is we start at our bill of material component in
our ontology and we use the linkage between that
and the part drawing to go see do I have any part
drawings? Do I have any other documentation that
might be in my system that's linked to this
component. After I do that as an assessment
I say actually I do have a drawing. I'm able to
pull one model ahead to actually take a look at
this and to see u what it thinks. So in this case
we have a prompt which is going to our model and
it's saying you're an expert in interpreting part
specifications sheets and mechanical drawings. So
given this image of it um can you extract and
list out all the materials for this part and
pay special attention to steel and aluminum and
you could easily modify this to include copper
etc in the future. And so what's happening if we
actually track this through in this panel here,
uh, if we open up that step that's equivalent, we
can see, okay, here's where the model went to that
drawing we just looked at earlier and it's pulling
out stainless steel. Yeah, I think important point
you're bringing up here because like we're now
talking about LM's reasoning, doing retrieval,
augmented generation across the ontology, but
also multimodal like we store multimodal data in
the ontology to to represent how this is really
happening. But that becomes very important on
the on the agentic side is now these agents are
accessing via either vector store in the ontology
for semantic search to find things or they're
going and looking at the images that are stored
as part of this so that one semantic object can
have this rich representation across all of those
different media types. And like this is a great
example why that's important when you're doing
the agentic flows is now it can also reason
across the different medias that we have too.
Exactly. Yeah. And what's even more
interesting about that too is that it
leads to even more use cases. So here's something
we're looking at materials for trade compliance,
but a lot of customers actually do workflows
where they do material harmonization where
they're kind of looking between um all of my
drawings in my engineering database to say,
could I be buying the same part under different
part numbers in different areas? Right. And so
that's like using the next use case that you build
on top of it to get even more value. Yeah. Yeah,
and I think that's the power of the ontology is
really the high level reuse, the malleability to
your use cases. Um, but you know, injecting that
extra layer of things on top of it. It's like,
no, I already have the ontology 90% there. I just
need some more objects. Let me go build that. Um,
think about it differently. And I think that's
where also then um these agentic workflows come
in as well is now I can start to string those
together across business processes to automate
more and more of a business. Exactly. And some
businesses may say, "Actually, I don't exactly
have the drawings readily available." But that's
okay, too, because that's where you can start to
use more of the reasoning parts. So, we actually
take this information and give it to a second
uh model a little bit later. And if there's any
drawing information available, we tell it to take
that into account. But it can also use things such
as part descriptions, some understanding if you
give it maybe the HTS description so that it can
kind of like do its best guess in the absence of
some of that other data to at least help you do
that prioritization workflow. So in this case,
um, we have a second model which is now assessing
based off of the description of the part, the part
number, and anything it was able to get out the
drawing. Does it contain steel or aluminum? Yes.
No. Right? And then at that point that's what's
then given back to this action in the ontology.
And then we're able to actually write this back
against the specific um component in that bill
of materials which is what was showing up in our
application. Yeah. So the other thing I noticed
here is you're using multiple different models in
one agent that flow too. So I saw Gemini 2 flash
uh for the kind of image extraction piece and
then now I've got GPD40 for reasoning pieces.
Uh I think that's pretty cool from a standpoint
is I can mix and match models for the right size,
the right use case even in one agent. Exactly.
Yeah. And I think that's like that's important.
You're also showing the test components and
evaluation like how do I evaluate this at scale?
But the last part I would call out here is like
these are actions defined in the ontologies. The
ontology is the guard rails for getting access
to data, the logic of the different components,
but also the actions because I want the agent
to take an action. And sometimes the agent says,
"Hey person, you need to review this." Other
times it's I write back to your SAP system,
your PLM to make this real. And so I think that's
the other piece here that's important is we can
drive those actions on guard rails through the
right security primitives back to source systems
to make it like you know scalable across hundreds
or thousands of these different use cases um very
quickly. Now let's go back to the application and
see the next step so that we can close this out.
So going back into the application, we can look
at where our component is and we can see we might
need to collect some supplier information now
because if it's partial steel aluminum, we may
not have that in our data. And so we want to go
to that component specific supplier to figure that
out. So if we click the take action button, that's
actually going to open up another window for us.
And here we can see that there's a proposed
supplier who's related to this component via
the anttology. And then we're going to ask a model
to actually start to generate that out for us so
that we can reach out to these suppliers. It's
put together this information. It's now going to
request the steel content, the weight, the country
of pore or smelled in the case of aluminum,
etc. So that way we can get all this information
together and we can send this out as an email to
the supplier. In this case, we actually already
got a response. So the system can actually now use
another agent which is actually going to read
through this and check, did we get the right
information back? If we didn't, we can request
further clarifications. But the other thing that
we can do is accept that supplier response. That's
going to show us that we parsed out the values
that they've sent back to us. And then when we
click submit, we can commit that to the ontology
and then now put together the entire package.
So we have all our supplier communications. We
have all our drawings available. We have the
bill of materials for the parts. Everything's
logged in and auditable in terms of a package.
And then we can see that while originally we
were getting tariffed on a $36 60 um unit price
of of a component, we've actually reduced that
because only $2 of the components um constituent
materials is actually steel and aluminum. So when
you're actually now compliant with the tariff um
it's actually reduced it by 88,000 $88,000 for the
year. Oh wow. Okay. So that that's cool that now
I'm simulating out finding solutions simulating
out the impact and then can make it real like and
understand what that impact is before I make it
um all with human and AI working together.
That's that's pretty cool. Exactly right. And
it's um if you just think about the scale of the
different systems here communicating to brokers
communicating to suppliers super super difficult
unless you have a platform like AIP. Yeah. and
and it's like it's easy to understand and one off.
It's but okay now go do this for 10,000. Um right
that's that's when you really need a system like
this to prioritize facilitate bring all the data
together and everything like that. Um that's
cool also because now I can track the impact
and success of these things. So from like an ROI
perspective for people to take on projects like
this you know having a hard ROI of the you know of
the money saved by being in compliance um that's
that's pretty powerful. Exactly. And it may not
even be with in terms of your filings. Perhaps you
have customers who have more control over their
supply chain and they might actually want to know
like when you're passing on potential tariff costs
on to them, how are you accurately passing those
costs on to them, right? Oh wow. Okay. So you're
that that facilitates the conversation when when
a tariff has has forced us to increase the price
to our customers to be able to say actually it's
because of these components. Here's what that cost
differential is to be fully transparent when you
have to make those changes. Exactly. And let's
say if you're making a sub assembly for a bigger
uh equipment manufacturer, you have to make sure
that you're properly allocating which tariff goes
to which manufacturer. Otherwise, like one
may say, how come I'm paying the tariff that
is on components going to the other guy, right?
Yep. Yep. Okay, that makes a lot of sense. Okay,
cool. So, that was awesome to see kind of in
action the flow of how things are integrated.
And I love always that when we talk about AIP,
it's not AI in your face. It's actually in the
background automating really that that autonomous
enterprise. But speaking of that, like what are
you seeing across customers and like what are
they looking for in the space? Why is this
moving so quickly? Good question. So because the
regulations are changing so quickly, um you have
to be very agile in order to adapt your system
so that you can respond to that. So, for example,
some of the other tariffs, um, if you had a USMCA
certification, you would actually be exempt from
them. But the problem is a lot of companies don't
necessarily manage their USMCA certifications
correctly. They expire every year. So, you really
need to have a helper, in this case, an AI agent,
which can actually run through those and say,
"Hey, like you're going to be importing a lot
of this part number, and you had a cert last year,
but you don't have one now. So, let's go collect
it." Another case is also in terms of just um if
you're creating new components because you're like
having revised products, you may not necessarily
be importing the same products this year that you
did last year, right? And so if you then go off
of historical lists, you're not actually going to
be seeing what's ahead of you and prioritizing
yourself correctly. Yeah. Yeah. So, and all of
this is moving so quickly. like how long does it
take customers to get spun up on something like
this? So, a workflow like this um typically takes
a couple days to get the first version set up and
then they can be off and running within about a
week, a week and a half. And that's also really
important because while going forward you want
to be compliant so you can have correct filings,
you do have an opportunity to actually go back
and correct your filings, but there's sort of
like a cliff that it approaches at which point you
can't actually correct anymore. So, the faster you
get going, um, the better that you can, um, make
sure that you're being correctly charged for your
tariffs. Wow. Okay. So, being able to set this up
in a few days to be able to start to recover these
things, get in compliance, it's never too late
to get started, I guess. And so, that that's a
it's a pretty good story across a lot of what we
do at Palanteer, but specifically in this where,
hey, things are just happening. I need to adjust
to my business. There's nothing else I can do
besides move quicker and be compliant and agile
with what's happening. And so I think that's a
pretty powerful story. What's the bigger vision
now that I have this bomb and I connected all
these system? Like what other things can I do
with that? Mhm. Well, that's a good question,
Chad, because it's really interesting that once
you've gone into your your engineering systems
such as your PLMs and your ERPs, put that
together. This is a really good uh starting
point to be able to do other use cases. So, for
example, back to the obsolescence management,
that's very valuable for how do you make sure
you're not sitting on different inventories,
doing the material harmonization where you're
analyzing across your spend potentially,
am I buying the same thing in multiple places?
And then even when we think about when we're
doing RFQS for future procurement needs, um
maybe now you can properly assess a vendor in
the United States to be awarded business in the
future because it's actually going to be cheaper.
Yes, it's that it's that balance and way off.
I think similar like cost of goods sold and
understanding really there all the way to sales
and supply chain. I think the bomb is really
the center of a manufacturing company. So it's
that that bleed off to other use cases that's so
powerful. Mhm. Even think production scheduling,
right? The only way you're going to know if
you don't have components to to actually build
that product on the line is if you can properly
traverse the bill of materials and go check your
inventories. Yes. Yes. So definitely it's cool.
It's a cool motivator to start with the bomb. I
think that leads to a lot of other use cases, but
you know, it's really about how do we help people
um move with what's important in their business
right now and it's everchanging. So, thanks a lot
Christopher for showing me this today. It's pretty
uh insightful to see this work and how do we do
these things cuz it on for surface it doesn't seem
that difficult but man in the details in at scale
this is very very hard. Exactly. Thank you Chad.